most people spend money on dumb things
which then forces them to do things they
don't want so step number one for most
people in here return their BMW and get
a Toyota BMW god dammit and honestly
that becomes the vulnerability why do
you own a BMW because I love the car
just the brand and I I love driving it
so I don't know so to me that's where it
gets interesting right do you or you
like what the brand does to make you
look to other people I don't know I'm
not assuming I know I don't have a point
do you have a point I know I have a
point I don't know you but I know in the
macro that 98 of people that buy a
Mercedes or BMW likes what it makes
other people think of them not that they
like it and that 487 dollars a month
versus what they really need which is a
hundred dollars a month is why they have
a job they hate because they're paying
for a life that means nothing the amount
of people in here that have a job they
hate and they buy things they don't care
about to impress people they don't give
a [__] about scares the [__] out of me